what's up everybody we are pond Finity
and welcome to another episode of
challenge pump in it in these two series
where you challenge us with your
craziest ideas related to table bands
will go through all of your comments
pick the most creative ones and make a
video out of them if your idea can speak
will feature thank you video shorter so
make sure to leave your ideas in the
comment section below
Marie Kowalski wants to play ten
consecutive shots with the edge of the
racket let's see how many we can get
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cut outs out Rick wants us to do five
hour onsen episodes that's true
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's how you do it
roopam douga wants to play table tennis
using a knife let's see how well we can
slice with this one
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks Nick Brian gave me I have my
racket tech to my foot and I'll try to
go around the net with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed
the video leave it a thumbs up and if
you're new to the channel subscribe
right here and watch the previous
episodes here until next time